merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur marc le fur dont le groupe
l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président cette
question s'adresse à vous monsieur le
premier ministre le gouvernement a pris
récemment la décision de financer une
nouvelle ligne tgv entre bordeaux et dax
et également entre bordeaux et toulouse
c'est très bien je m'en réjouis pour nos
amis du sud ouest vous avez fait preuve
de volontarisme
je vous demande monsieur le premier
ministre de faire preuve du même
volontarisme pour d'autres projets et en
particulier pour les aménagements
nécessaires de la ligne tgv entre rennes
et brest et entre rennes et quimper
le sujet c'est de mettre à trois heures
les villes de brest et de quimper à
trois heures de paris
c'étaient les engagements initiaux du
projet que vous portiez naguère il y a
eu des études il y a eu des débats est
pour le moment strictement aucune
décision dans les 10 15 ans qui viennent
les six extrémités notre hexagone vont
tout est desservi par une ligne tgv à
l'exception de l'ouest et à l'exception
de la bretagne
vous comprenez bien que cela suscite un
sentiment de relégation
voire de discrimination à l'encontre de
l'ouest breton sentiment qui n'est pas
compris ceci intervient à un moment où
les déceptions s'accumulent pour les
bretons vous aviez promis 3 milliards
vous même monsieur le ministre votre
prédécesseur avait promis 2 milliards on
n'a strictement rien vu venir
le contrat de plan est tellement
décevant qu'il a été signé en catimini
presque clandestinement
parce qu'il n'y avait rien à afficher
voilà les réalités la crise agricole
impact toute une région
voilà la réalité du moment ces
déceptions se multiplient jusqu'à la
décentralisation d'ifremer
monsieur le premier ministre cette
décentralisation d'ifremer qui est une
petite chose que vous aviez engagé et
c'était très bien et qui aujourd'hui
n'aboutit pas si ce lien dans ce
contentieux malmené alors la surprise et
a essayé de nous rassurer alain vidalis
ministre des transports de la mer et de
la pêche
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député vous avez rappelé la décision qui
a été prise par le gouvernement qui est
des décisions de poursuivre la procédure
concernant la lgv paris bordeaux
toulouse et bordeaux dax avec trois
éléments nouveaux depuis la publication
du rapport d' enquêtes qui sont d'une
part la réponse évidemment de réseau
ferré de france
ensuite une étude complémentaire qui
avait été fait sur les solutions
alternatives c'est à dire la ligne
actuelle et surtout la décision de
l'europe de financer l'ensemble des
études sur sur ce tracé et donc avec
l'ensemble ces éléments nous avons
décidé de poursuivre ce dossier
extrêmement important puisque c'est non
seulement l'arc atlantique mais aussi la
liaison avec l'espagne et les toulouse
la quatrième agglomération alors vous
opposer ce dossier avec le dossier de
liaison un nouvel ouest bretagne pays de
loire
monsieur le furent vous connaissez
suffisamment les procédures pour savoir
qu'il y a toujours comme pour gpso comme
dans ce cas une première phase que cette
première phase
ça s'appelle le débat public est que ce
débat public est une phase préalable
messieurs le fur quel est le
gouvernement qu'elle ait la majorité qui
sur cette ligne a lancé le débat public
c'est ce gouvernement c'est cette
majorité qui a lancé le débat public à
la fin de 2013 ce débat public abouti
début 2015 au dépôt d'un rapport sur la
base duquel vous le savez parfaitement
on y avait plusieurs options une
solution savidan identifiés et
aujourd'hui on est en train de
travailler pour la poursuite du débat
public comme la commission du débat
public l'avait demandé que dans les
contrats de plan que dans les contrats
de plan qui ont été signés non pas quand
décidemment mai par le premier ministre
lui-même
il ya 40 millions d'euros pour ce
financement donc cette procédure suit
son cours cette majorité l'a retenu
cette majorité et les pays de loire et
la bretagne
les finances vous me permettrez monsieur
le furent à la fin de penser que votre
question est tellement incohérente
qu'elle a un petit pan maire de campagne
électorale monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame bernard